we have a voicemail number that number
is a number you can call anytime
if you have anything you want to tell me
the number is 219
to david p
219
to david p that's 219 232
here's a caller asking why i won't
debate
without considering
another possibility take a listen
hey davey boy i just it's me again i see
you haven't responded to me ever so i'm
just gonna
give you this one
question okay i don't know anything
about other voicemails this is the only
voicemail i'm aware of from this guy
why don't you ever debate people who are
actually smarter than you like ben
shapiro or candace owens or
kim kleisick
hey i don't know who that kim klick i
don't know the first two i know maybe
even larry elder
because you know there
or i have a better idea debate dave
rubin sure or chad hannity or the
smartest person of them all tucker
carlson okay because you know
just wondering bye yeah
i am glad to debate any of them have you
ever considered maybe they
don't have an interest in debating me
either because they see me as not worth
their time
or for whatever reason don't want to as
many of you might remember
at the political
media conference politicon a couple
years ago
i was told by organizers you and kyle
kulinski
will be debating charlie kirk and
candace owens and i said great i'll be
there
we then found out that candace owens has
not did not accept that offer
later candace said
i didn't wasn't even presented with that
offer now
politicon does often do this thing where
they try to play people off of each
other and they go hey we've got candace
and charlie to debate you you want to do
it and then you go yes
then they go to charles uh charlie and
candace and they go hey david pakman and
kyle kalinski want to debate you and
they go no we're not interested they
sometimes they do lie about who is
accepted it's unfortunately a common
tactic
maybe candace owens turned it down maybe
she didn't but the point here is
a lot of these folks have no interest in
debating me dave rubin is welcome on
this show any time i tried to get on his
show when i was in la and he you know
didn't want to do it he was busy
whatever so
for a second stop to think that
maybe it's the other people who don't
want to debate me
i don't know something to think about we
have a great bonus for a bonus show for
you today
today is the launch date for the truth
social app this is trump's new social
media app it looks just like twitter i
tried to sign up
couldn't do it we're going to talk about
it it's a very interesting uh
interesting project
the us is now
energy independent from the standpoint
of petroleum production and consumption
wait a second i thought trump said we're
no longer energy independent but we were
under him well we've got the facts
and joe biden has canceled 415
million dollars of student loans
uh making him the president who has
cancelled the most student loans of any
president in history now we should
inflation adjust that of course
very interesting stories all of which
will be on two days bonus show which you
can sign up for at join
pacman.com
also next monday
i will be delivering the state of the
show address
on tuesday next tuesday joe biden is
delivering the state of the union
address i will be delivering on monday
the state of the show address and it is
going to be
inspirational
it is going to be
thematic in many ways related to things
on the show uh it's gonna be very very
good i look forward to sharing with you
what's been going on at the david pakman
show we will see you tomorrow or if you
are a member at joinpakman.com
the bonus show starts
in mere minutes